la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Philippe Tabarro pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
madame la Première ministre les classes
moyennes ne croient plus et n'écoutent
plus ceux qui les déposaient
cette semaine dans un grand quotidien
c'est une illustration parfaite du
ressenti des Français à la mise en place
forcée des zones affaiblissement
mobilité notre groupe ici au Sénat l'a
rappelé il y a quelques jours lors d'un
débat que nous avons souhaité après la
mise en place chaotique des ZFE du Grand
Paris à Toulouse en passant par
Strasbourg ni sous Toulon nous y avons
défendu une vision équilibrée entre le
tout voiture que nous récupérons et le
jusqu'au-boutisme environnemental qui
voudrait supprimer tous les véhicules
les Français sont-ils informés que 40%
d'entre eux vont devoir dans les
prochaines années amener leur véhicule à
la casse non
l'industrie automobile française et je
dis bien française est-elle prête à
cette transformation vers le tout
électrique non d'après monsieur Tavares
lavitaillement est-il suffisant et
l'impact de la crise énergétique
intégrée au cou et au déploiement des
bornes électriques non la logistique
urbaine est-elle organisée pour nos
petits artisans et leurs véhicules
utilitaires non les contrôles sont il
efficaces et efficients non l'offre de
transport en commun enfin est-elle
suffisante ponctuelle et
Eric tel l'ensemble de notre pays non
les ZF eux tels que vous les avez mises
en place sont un cafard à homme tout est
à l'envers madame la Première ministre
avez-vous conscience que ces ZF
pourraient être l'étincelle de nouveaux
blocages allez vous mettre fin à cette
marche forcée en sens inverse
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministres de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires monsieur
Béchu monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Tabarro
y a-t-il ici des gens qui pensent que la
question des décès par la pollution
atmosphérique est un sujet secondaire
y a-t-il ici des gens qui contestent la
nécessité de lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique
y a-t-il ici des gens qui considèrent
qu'il faut faire confiance aux élus
locaux quand on met en place des
politiques
et bien mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et monsieur le sénateur
Tabarro vous avez dressé la feuille de
route qui est la nôtre
les zones à faible émission
affaiblission de quoi s'agit-il d'une
invention française non ça existe dans
14 pays d'Europe la première a été mise
en place en 1996 en Suède
est-ce que ce dispositif concerne 40%
des automobilistes non il concerne les
agglomérations qui sont en dépassement
de seuil à la suite de la condamnation
par la Cour de justice des Communautés
européennes et par le Conseil d'État le
seul calendrier fixé par l'État je n'ai
aucun doute sur le fait que vous les
rassurer nos concitoyens et faire en
sorte que nous prenions les bonnes
décisions je vous demande juste
d'entendre ce qu'est l'état du droit
l'état du droit c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
calendrier
fixé par l'État par rapport aux
véhicules professionnels l'état du droit
c'est que les seuils de restriction
dépendent des dépassements de la
pollution de l'air et qu'à la minute où
nous nous parlons contrairement à ce que
certains disent c'est nid d'où le pays
ni 43 agglomérations qui sont concernés
par un calendrier restrictif le seul
calendrier restrictifié par la loi c'est
la sortie des critères 5 si vous êtes en
dépassement de seuil au 1er janvier 2023
critères 4 au 1er janvier 2024 critères
3 au 1er janvier 2025 combien avons-nous
aujourd'hui d'agglomération en
dépassement de seuil on en a moins de 10
les autres elles ont à la fois une
attitude sur la mise en place de mesures
qui permettent d'atteindre les objectifs
puisque c'est une obligation de
résultats pas une obligation de moyens
les critiques que vous avez émises et
dont je me suis réjoui dans cette
hémicycle et qui était à la fois plus
nuancée et plus constructive que le
caractère condensé de la question elles
nous ont conduit à mettre en place un
groupe de travail qui associe qui la
métropole de Toulouse est celle de
Strasbourg pour faire en sorte de
proposer des solutions
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre je regrette
votre absence de réponse car c'est vous
qui avez également souhaité comme
ministre des Transports à l'époque ces
ZFE écoutez s'il vous plaît accompagner
nos concitoyens pour que les EDF ne
deviennent pas un sacrifice de plus pour
les Français
[Applaudissements]